[Música]
y
cómo
quiero contaros para empezar una
historia que a mí como psicólogo me
fascina
en el año 1972 los ocupantes de la casa
blanca estaban preocupados por una
invasión que temían que tuviese lugar en
territorio norteamericano
no una invasión de comunista como en
aquella película de chuck norris de los
años 80 sino una invasión de yonquis y
esos yanquis no eran otros que los
soldados americanos destinados en
vietnam porque según parece el consumo
de droga en el ejército americano
destinado en vietnam alcanzamos los
niveles tan astronómicos que formaba
parte de la vida y de la cultura de allí
igual que el rock and roll o el disparar
la gente pobre los soldados americanos
previos a ser destinados a vietnam
mostraban un patrón de consumo
prácticamente inexistente menos del 1%
eran adictos o consumían habitualmente
alguna sustancia la mayoría nunca habían
probado nada
pero llegaban a vietnam y aquello
parecía un poblado de venta de drogas o
un máster a las cinco de la mañana la
mitad de ellos consumía drogas varias
veces múltiples veces a lo largo de su
periodo allí turnos que muchas veces
eran de 13 meses 1 de cada 5 1 de cada 5
eran adictos claro esto generaba una
enorme preocupación en el gobierno
porque lógicamente pensaban que vamos a
hacer con esta gente cuando vuelvan aquí
que vamos a hacer con miles de adictos a
la droga sueltos por nuestras calles con
entrenamiento militar incapaces de
integrarse en sociedad la imagen era
prácticamente un apocalipsis zombie se
imaginaban por ejemplo como la portada
la revista 'time' que los más
vulnerables serían los negros los pobres
la gente con pocos estudios pero esto no
era cierto el patrón de consumo no
dependía de la raza no dependía de la
clase social no dependía de ningún
factor que ellos pudieran aislar
afectaba a todo el mundo por igual la
gente podía consumir por estar en
combate o no podía consumir por haber
tenido una experiencia traumática o no
a veces alguno empezaban a consumir
porque en el hospital les administraba
morfina para sus heridas pero muchos
simplemente consumían porque era lo que
hacía todo el mundo
las explicaciones tradicionales no
parecían dar cuenta de que pasaba así
que se imaginaban bandas como en las
películas se nota que me gustan las
películas de los 80 verdad como en the
warriors bandas corriendo por las calles
sembrando el caos veterano peligrosísimo
incapaces de incorporarse a la vida
normal un desastre y qué es lo que pasó
no pasó nada
a la vuelta del despliegue de vietnam el
1 por ciento de los soldados que
consumían drogas mantuvieron el hábito
de consumo esto es el mismo porcentaje
que consumían antes de la guerra ni más
ni menos el resto de soldados en un
período promedio de un año dejaron de
consumir imaginaros todos los cuñados de
las tertulias televisivas y de radios
completamente desconcertados después de
pasarse mucho tiempo preocupándose y
comiéndose la cabeza con esto y que la
cosa era un poco como un anticlímax no
ibas a tener un apocalipsis si no
tuviste nada
qué corte de rollo
qué pasó la respuesta o una posible
respuesta vino unos años después en 1978
de la mano de un psicólogo llamado brush
alexander que hizo una serie de
experimentos muy conocidos como el rat
parque el parque de ratas en estos
experimentos alexander utilizaba un
colectivo de ratas wistar que son los
mejores amigos del psicólogo
experimental después del perro
y las separaba en dos grupos uno de los
grupos estaba más o menos en una cárcel
y el otro estaba en un resort en
puntacana para que nos hagamos una idea
o sea el grupo eran ratas que estaban en
las típicas jaulas de laboratorio
aislada y separadas de otra rata y con
muy poca cosa que hacer a lo largo del
día el otro grupo el del resort estaba
en el rat park el raspar que era un
espacio muy grande lleno de túneles y
sitios donde las ratas podían jugar
podían explorar podían interactuar con
otra rata ambos grupos tenían depósitos
de agua con morfina a su disposición y
agua sin morfina las ratas podían auto
administrarse morfina siempre que
quisieran vamos party heart total
y alexander encontró que las ratas que
estaban en la cárcel se administraban
mucho más frecuente la morfina y por
tanto desarrollaban más fácilmente
hábitos de adicción pero que las ratas
que tenían otras cosas que hacer a
menudo evitaban el agua con morfina y se
dedicaban puede ser jugar con otras
ratas explorar y hacer cosas de rata ya
pasárselo bien algunas ratas de este
grupo se enganchaban a la morfina por
supuesto pero eran muy pocas
esto chocaba frontalmente con la
concepción de que las drogas eran
adictivas en sí mismas porque es en la
primera prueba de que quizá el entorno
también tiene algo que ver y parece que
estos experimentos eran generalizables a
humanos viendo cómo se comportaban los
soldados americanos que volvían de
vietnam por supuesto las drogas tienen
capacidad de causar adicción pero no es
toda la historia el entorno parece tener
también un peso esto es los soldados
salían de un entorno en el que el
consumo de drogas era normal volvían a
sus casas muchos de ellos regresaban con
sus familias sus seres queridos
encontraban un trabajo desarrollaban
relaciones sanas
y lo dejaban tan simple como eso
he empezado con esta historia porque
como psicólogos el si la gente puede
cambiar y cómo cambiamos es parte
esencial de mi trabajo de nuestro
trabajo los psicólogos somos
modificadores de conducta ya sea en la
consulta ayudando a un paciente a
superar un problema ya sea en una
empresa desarrollando a un equipo para
que adopten una nueva forma de trabajar
ya sea en una escuela un orientador
tratando de que un alumno adquiera
hábitos de estudio
lo que hacemos es estudiar cómo cambiar
a la gente de forma que la gente cambie
para mejor y para conseguir sus
objetivos y claro lo que la gente cree
que pasa muchas veces no es lo que
realmente pasa cuando hablamos de
conducta humana la psicología popular
tiene poco que ver con la psicología
científica y una de las ideas reinas en
lo tocante a la capacidad de cambiar de
los seres humanos es la idea de que para
cambiar hace falta mucha fuerza de
voluntad que es la razón o la excusa por
la que te apuntas al gimnasio vas dos
semanas y luego te pegas seis meses
pagando y no vas nunca porque total vas
a ir la semana que viene saludo a mi
gimnasio por cierto de aquí
en la razón por la que empiezas una
dieta pero en cuanto tienes un mal día
en tripa en la cara de lado y de galleta
y de beber albóndiga
es la razón por la que tú eres
estudiantes y estudiar examen el día
antes todos los cursos te juras que este
no va a ser así pero al final siempre
acabas cayendo porque tienes que salir
de farra porque no tienes voluntad otra
gente si la tiene por eso ellos si
pueden cambiar pero tú no tú no tienes
voluntad
esa idea de hecho ha tenido cierto
predicamento en la psicología en los
últimos años se puso bastante en relieve
un modelo desarrollado por el psicólogo
roy baumeister que se llamaba modelo de
agotamiento del ego el modelo de
agotamiento del ego ego de prisión en
inglés básicamente estipula que la
voluntad sería un recurso energético
limitado como un depósito de gasolina y
que se agotan las medidas que tenemos
que tomar decisiones difíciles que nos
cuestan los hábitos no nos cuestan
voluntad las decisiones si por ejemplo
comerme el brócoli en vez de comerme un
bollo a medida que vamos tomando
decisiones difíciles se nos vamos
quedando sin voluntad a lo largo del día
de forma que finalmente acabamos cayendo
en nuestros viejos hábitos y además la
tentación por eso la mayoría de la
infidelidades se producen por la noche
las dietas suelen romperse por la noche
y todas estas cosas
el problema es que este modelo no
aplaude es todavía que no estoy dando
una excusa para ponerle los cuernos a
nadie
el problema con esto es que
este modelo está siendo contestado
porque está teniendo dificultades para
replicar no porque no pueda haber una
cierta verdad en esto yo creo que hay
algo de esto sino porque se deja fuera
una parte muy importante que es el
contexto una cosa que los modificadores
de conducta sabemos es que los seres
humanos como cualquier otro organismo
reaccionamos fundamentalmente a las
señales que nuestro contexto nos envía
del mismo modo que por ejemplo cruzamos
la calle cuando vemos un semáforo en
verde o cuando vemos un signo como este
no nos acercamos nos gusta pensar que
tenemos libre albedrío y que no tomamos
decisiones porque nos gusta pensar que
somos seres racionales pero como dice
siniestro total somos seres racionales
porque tomamos las raciones de los bares
o sea que no la mayoría de las cosas que
habéis hecho en el día de hoy no tienen
una pizca de decisión racional por
vuestra parte y muchas veces respondemos
al entorno de manera que están
determinadas por nuestra genética
nuestra historia de aprendizaje de
nuestras experiencias y nuestros hábitos
y de eso es de lo que yo quiero hablar
especialmente hoy algunos psicólogos
para explicar por qué es difícil cambiar
han concebido una metáfora en la que
esto entender que es una metáfora la
conducta no es así pero es una forma
fácil de entender
es una simplificación conciben a la
persona como un jinete hindú montado en
su elefante vale que va por una selva
por un camino a través de la selva el
jinete y el elefante representan a la
persona y la selva y el camino
representan el contexto el entorno en el
que esta persona se mueve
el jinete por tanto representa la parte
que hace planes a largo plazo el jinete
el que hace los propósitos de año nuevo
el cine está motivado motiva el elefante
es todo lo demás el elefante es nuestra
gratificación nuestro gusto por la
gratificación instantánea nuestros
hábitos nuestra emocionalidad
el elefante es el que quiere comerse el
bollo ahora aunque el jinete ha decidido
que lo que tocaba comerse un plato de
quinoa ecológica con salmón hervido de
piscifactorías responsable
el elefante quiere llamar a tu ex
borracho perdido alado de la mañana para
decirle que a ver si volvéis
el elefante es el que sabe que tiene que
estudiar pero acaba de salir una
temporada de juego de tronos y lo que
quiere es sentarse delante de la tele y
ver se le entera al elefante no le gusta
mojarse ni sudando y cuando llueve por
eso cuando llueve no somos capaces de ir
al gimnasio de salir a correr porque es
que llueve y que yo me gusta más la
mantita al elefante le gustan las cosas
las que está acostumbrados
al elefante le gusta hasta tu ex
es un poco como si ortega y gasset
hubiera dicho yo soy yo y mi
circunstancia pero disfrazado de indio y
montaban un [ __ ] de cinco toneladas
claro que pasa el elefante es muy grande
el jinete muy pequeños el elefante se le
pone la trompa tirar en una dirección el
jinete lo único que pasar es dejarse
llevar generalmente acabando en mañana
de resaca y arrepentimiento
así es como jonathan hai te explica esta
experiencia que todos hemos tenido de
tener perfectamente claro qué es lo que
hay que hacer y hacer otra cosa
así como se puede explicar porque muchas
veces nuestros hábitos que están
gobernados por el entorno y responden a
señales del entorno tienen más fuerza
que nuestras intenciones que las cosas
que nosotros intentamos utilizar como
disparadores de la conducta
el entorno no sólo incluye el entorno
físico con nuestras señales de tira por
aquí párate aquí incluye también el
entorno social las personas con las que
nos relacionamos la cultura en la que
vivimos si pensáis que es poco
importante he escuchado una cosa en el
año 2007 un estudio médico de la
universidad de harvard encontró que si
uno de vosotros se pone obeso desarrolla
obesidad todos sus amigos íntimos
multiplican por tres la posibilidad de
ponerse ese porro y esto no es porque
vais todos juntos a un restaurante en
porcar o no si tú vives en san francisco
y tu amigo vive en nueva york y tenéis
un contacto constante y frecuente tu
amigo se pone ese porro igual él te
influye tú le influye
el entorno pesa tanto en nosotros que
podemos cambiar nuestro hábitos
alimentarios sin darnos ni cuenta
el entorno puede impedirnos actuar o
puede obligarnos hacer cosas estúpidas
como por ejemplo dedican a consumir
heroína mientras estamos en la guerra de
vietnam porque todo el mundo lo hace hay
un experimento clásico de la universidad
de columbia en la que se cogen a
estudiantes y se les dice que van a
hacer unos cuestionarios los estudiantes
pueden estar solos o en grupos de 3 los
estudiantes
están rellenando el cuestionario cuando
empieza a ocurrir una emergencia por una
reja escondida en la pared empieza a
entrar humo a borbotones hasta llenar la
sala si el estudiante está solo hay un
75 por ciento de posibilidades de que se
levante inmediatamente vaya a pedir
ayuda y de la alarma pero cuando el
estudiante está con más gente sólo el 38
por ciento de las veces se levantan y
piden ayuda pensarlo el 62 por ciento de
los estudiantes se quedaron sentados
como capullo tragando humo porque todos
estaban esperando a que alguien hiciera
algo y como nadie hacía nada todo el
mundo se quedaba quieto en una situación
desconocida el contexto nos dice que
tenemos que hacer y si no recibimos
señales del contexto no hacemos nada
como vosotros ahora que está entrando
aquí humo y estáis todo aquí calla
mirándome
el contexto determina y el contexto
inhibe nuestras conductas
también se puede usar para el bien de
hecho un pequeño cambio contextual puede
provocar enormes cambios de conducta un
ejemplo que me encanta de esto porque
además tiene una amplia aplicación es un
experimento que realizaron en el
hospital kaiser south en san francisco
desarrollado por la jefa de enfermeras
beck y richards bay que richards quería
disminuir los errores en la
administración de medicamentos por parte
de las enfermeras porque un error en la
administración del medicamento podría
ser fatal la fuente de estos errores
generalmente eran las distracciones de
gente que interrumpía la enfermera
preguntaba de cualquier cosas médicos
enfermeras otros pacientes familiares de
pacientes en la tuna que pasaba por allí
quien fuese
y decidió usar un simple cambio en el
entorno para que esas enfermeras no
fueran distraídas que fue esto chalecos
reflectantes cutres feos como un cáncer
de estos que se compran en cualquier
tienda para cambiar neumáticos y una
regla
si llevas el chaleco puesto es que estás
poniendo medicación si estás con el
chaleco puesto nadie te puede hablar y
tú no debes contestar a nadie las
enfermeras por supuesto lo odiaban lo
odiaban con toda su alma porque les
pareció un castigo una muestra de que
eran incompetentes en su trabajo sin
embargo a los pocos meses de iniciar el
estudio los errores en administración de
medicamentos bajaron un 47% nadie tuvo
que hacer ningún esfuerzo de voluntad
nadie tuvo que cambiar nada
conscientemente solo esa sencilla norma
y ese cambio en el entorno provocaron un
decisivo cambio de conducta claro no
siempre podemos cambiar el entorno para
iniciar un hábito no te puedes ir de
vacaciones a bora bora cada vez que
quieres aprender un hábito nuevo aunque
está comprobado que es más fácil dejar
de fumar en vacaciones que en casa
porque en vacaciones no tienes las
señales del contexto que te invitan a
fumar
entonces qué hacemos cuando queremos
iniciar un hábito un psicólogo de la
universidad de nueva york llamado peter
goldwaser desarrolló una técnica llamada
desencadenantes de la acción que es una
forma en la que nosotros podemos
anticipar una situación en la que
disparamos una conducta poniendo así el
control de nuestra conducta bajo una
señal del contexto por ejemplo si yo soy
un estudiante y tengo la posibilidad de
hacer un trabajo opcional para ganar
unos puntos extra tengo más
posibilidades de hacer el trabajo en vez
de quedarme dormido si escribo en un
papel haré el trabajo el sábado tal a
las 9 de la mañana en el despacho de mi
padre justo antes de que se levanten
porque porque cuando nosotros hacemos
eso predisponemos a nuestro organismo a
reaccionar a la señal desde el entorno
de manera que entrar en ese entorno
dispara la conducta esta técnica ha
tenido múltiples aplicaciones en el
ámbito de la salud y se han obtenido
resultados espectaculares a la hora de
conseguir que por ejemplo pacientes
ancianos que han recibido prótesis de
cadera y de rodilla adopten hábitos de
salud de moverse en vez de quedarse
postrados por el dolor acelerando
significativamente sus recuperaciones en
los hábitos que son difíciles que el
sujeto percibe como difíciles de
adquirir
creación de desencadenantes de intención
multiplica por tres las posibilidades de
éxito por tres de un 22 a un 62 por
ciento en promedio en mi propia práctica
como psicólogo esta técnica se ha
probado valiosa porque algunas de las
tareas terapéuticas que los pacientes
tienen que hacer son pesadas por ejemplo
en terapia cognitiva una de las técnicas
fundamentales es llevar un registro de
tus pensamientos de forma que tú puedas
detectar los pensamientos disfuncionales
que te causan ansiedad depresión y otras
emociones negativas y sustituirlos por
pensamientos racionales la mayoría de la
gente no tiene hábito de llevar un
diario para la mayoría de personas es
difícil sentarse escribir cuando yo con
mis pacientes acuerdo unos
desencadenantes de la conducta de cuándo
y cómo van a sentarse a escribir los
pacientes aumentan enormemente las
probabilidades de llevar a cabo la tarea
y por tanto aumentan enormemente las
probabilidades de que la terapia sea
eficaz así que en resumen
las personas podemos cambiar
y podemos cambiar constantemente lo
hacemos constantemente pero la mayor
parte de las veces nuestros cambios
pueden producirse y mantenerse con mucha
facilidad si observamos el entorno y
observamos como el entorno nos influye y
cómo le influimos al entorno como el
entorno facilita lo que queremos hacer o
dificulta lo que queremos hacer el
cambio es perfectamente posible pero al
contrario de lo que muchas personas
creen no tiene absolutamente nada que
ver con la fuerza de voluntad muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]